they were walking in the road oh I know
where I don't worry this I think I'm
pretty sure I know which one he's from
that one right there
I'm pretty sure hey buddy you wanna come
to me are you good over there all right
let's go let me
haengsuk can you pull over here for me
one second do you recognize me you don't
recognize me I was here last time when
this happened do you remember that and
your son today was in the street walking
out on us one and luckily some nice
ladies saw him and stopped before he got
smushed by a freaking car you know what
were you guys doing in there just
sleeping yeah pretend blanket back
I'll have enough of it but Oh both of
you you're both are getting arrested to
get your kid dress
child neglect Wow what do you mean why
I've seen the back of my car I'll have
enough of the gun sit in the back get in
there